foreign
[Music]
welcome to another episode of careful
boys we have with us Mr Jake Tran in the
Hachi
Jake Long Jake Long Train I have no idea
what's happening okay so you've never
seen Hot Seat no the show with the hot
seat in the hot and the higher questions
yep there it is wow Steve came up with
that by himself wow so this is a little
segment where all we do is we just ask
you increasingly hotter questions that
get a little more personal sometimes
borderline intrusive nobody's ever left
this show without getting canceled yep
awesome yeah so you're in good hands so
I hope you fulfilled every one of your
career goals to this point this is it I
mean how worse can it go that's a good
attitude wait till the first question so
our first question we always like to
start off with Bart who begins with the
absolute coldest question imaginable
take it away for SEO purposes
SEO that's right
how do you spell caterpillar backwards
caterpillar backwards
r a
there's no way I could even keep track
of it
let me let me I don't even know how to
spell kind of Pull It Forward a-l-l okay
no no no no don't go yet don't go yet
Kate Blanchett
all right okay
r-a-l-l uh
e p
a t a c you're I think you missed one so
it's cat caterpillar with the eye okay
unless that's caterpillar the brand he's
like no he's like okay what happens now
wow absolutely nothing well now we get
sidetracked and debate this for eight
minutes
we didn't have the budget the bud for
slime to come pouring down
that budget I'll recover you in
caterpillars
shall not be good oh what was your
family life like family life
um typical Asian parents so your dad
beat your mom or no
well you said typically right yeah
typical Asian parents thought you know
don't show affection to you and uh
expect a lot of you you know my dad was
surprisingly supportive all these
content with me trying YouTube really my
mom was not uh because
when I started this channel I quit my
web development job that I landed at 20
years old and it paid like 40 bucks an
hour which was like 80k a year if I did
a full time damn at 20 years old
I landed that job while I was still in
college Then I Dropped Out
yeah my mom was like super devastated
that I quit that job because
I had to achieve like everything that
secured me yeah yeah yeah yeah but did
you go like but Mom I have something way
[ __ ] better yeah that's gonna be
cracking I was making zero dollars back
then but do you slam dunk on her now
like you never believe
now she's like you know Jake I remember
when you said you wanted to make like
10K a month and I totally didn't believe
you and uh now she's she's like super
happy that's so cool she's so like open
and like honest about that yeah you
think she's gotten soft as she's gotten
older
oh sure because that happened to this
guy I got something your parents got
soft on you a little bit because as
they're aging right you you've told us
that they're my dad got softer but my
mom got meaner I think that [ __ ]
menopause is just real Fair it is yeah
be prepared for that oh that's true your
parents are probably like 35 huh they're
probably our age bro [ __ ] sake what am
I talking like their new age yeah what
am I talking about that's what they're
mad at they're like no you should be in
web three you idiot
no um
yeah my parents have kind of just come
to accept that I'm just gonna do
whatever I want uh because I just like
always rebelled against them and uh kind
of just found my own way but yeah what's
something you never told your parents
before never told you you don't tell
them a lot of things right yeah yeah a
lot of things
um or what's something you might know
you'll never tell them well if they
watch this they're gonna find out
they're not gonna watch this they're not
gonna watch parents for some reason
don't find this [ __ ] nobody really does
parents don't like this show oh you know
uh
no drugs and stuff oh they don't know
that you've done drugs yeah don't blow
up a spot dog damn yeah sorry Mom Dad
does and stuff include eating stripper
[ __ ] not I'm just asking this
question over here it's hooker [ __ ]
what's up I can either confirm nor deny
okay I understood it's a good man you
were recently in uh Tomorrowland yes how
was that which is a massive Rave out
world's biggest Festival world's biggest
Festival bigger than EDC wow yeah where
was that it was in Belgium yeah whoa
yeah so it was pretty interesting I've
found the Rave culture here to be
actually a lot better really I believe
over there like festivals and Raves are
a lot more common so I hear people like
dress up they go like oh no they go all
out they're like they get super [ __ ]
up yeah yeah uh outfits like that yeah
and everyone's like overly overly nice
over there people are just like
we're less [ __ ] up people seem like
more sober normal outfits I agree but
they're not taking enough ecstasy or
something it's not a once in a lifetime
thing than most people out there yeah
exactly
um yeah some people were on drugs but
most people seem like just on alcohol or
sober so it's like the La Fair well it's
still it's still a good vibe yeah kind
of like that yeah it was more like a
spectacle it felt like Disneyland like
giant stages
naked and like they were ready to Rave
out and you're just like yeah it seemed
like uh you can tell which ones were The
Americans really oh yeah another thing
that I found that was very distasteful
um people don't seem to like Asians over
there as much as over here really aren't
as normal no yeah over there especially
uh especially with French people like
French people just like don't like they
just don't like people what do they do
what do they do to you they're like
French people so
um we were walking uh leaving the venue
one night and uh my friend is Chinese
and she accidentally bumped into a guy
like this big french guy and uh she
apologized and I he like made like Asian
noises like like ching chong or
something yeah stuff like that like
bowed but was he like you was he being
sarcastic or he was being he was being
like he's being sincere do that
sarcastic though do Asian did you guys
French back to him like
we were walking away or else I would
have like beat him up but yeah stuff
like that small little things like that
there's just no recourse for Behavior
like that yeah dude the French are the
worst anyway we dunk on them all the
time yeah I I found that to be the case
I haven't met and I'm not kidding I
haven't been a single French person who
was worth a second conversation yo
French people who like move out of
France and like move to America they're
chill yeah they all right not in my book
pal not not my not my [ __ ] French
teacher in high school my French teacher
okay no one liked her dude I mean who
likes language teachers that's true but
this isn't my hot seat though have you
seen that Tyler the Creator clip when
he's in Paris and then this French uh
like interviewer he's like so how do you
like it in Paris and then he's all like
it [ __ ] sucks it smells like [ __ ]
everybody here is mean as [ __ ] I don't
like it we're not [ __ ] doing this he
goes name one thing about Paris that you
you know was new to you he goes nothing
if [ __ ] there's the style here just [ __ ]
and [ __ ] people here are [ __ ] 30 they
stink it was so [ __ ] I love how the
interviewer just sticks to this question
so he doesn't know what to do you get
reacted in the moment and he goes into
the second blood yeah so like what do
you what do you love about friends and
what do you not love about friends
like I [ __ ] hate it dude this [ __ ]
sucks it's like Nick he's like [ __ ]
blows here dude and then the reaction of
the room was like everyone was like
quiet and then all you hear is Tyler
going like no are you are you [ __ ]
listening to me we're not doing this I
hate it here dude I'm surprised the
French camera guy was even getting this
and he wasn't just like [ __ ] off
smoking a cigarette going on strike and
[ __ ] dude being a piece of [ __ ]
basically yeah
that was my conclusion
but French food is still very good
really I thought it was so [ __ ]
what's your favorite French food grapes
what's your favorite French food you
know
King
their actual meals are like very simple
like steak but fries it's like all their
ingredients are Super Fresh and natural
like it comes with a farm right next to
it oh that's true yeah you oh yeah
you're from Arizona you would think
that's that's crazy
fair enough
that's not that crazy but is that your
first time in Europe no
um second or third oh [ __ ] man of the
[ __ ] world uh what's your favorite
place you've been to favorite place I've
been to
um
you know America Still Feels Like Home
the most but I really like Amsterdam
people bro Anthony I'm sick it's so sick
people are super nice there especially
the girls for some reason do they like
Angels over there especially the girls
I'm paying to have sex with me right
they're like extra nice until after you
come yeah they're like get the [ __ ] out
and I'm like what happened to the other
girl that was like come here you're so
ice cold you're a typical woman
always there for the money that's all
they care about but I kind of view that
as like New York where it's like a
Melting Pot but people are actually nice
and the food is amazing there yeah uh
super diverse
mushrooms so many options of [ __ ] you
can eat too so you said uh your YouTube
um makes pretty good money now and when
you first I guess like were more
financially well off what was the first
thing you indulged in first thing I
indulge then yeah cool
um
baby extra extra large extra extra large
version it's a Vietnamese tapioca
dessert I mean I bought my pear I still
draw the same car I bought my parents a
house oh [ __ ] that's pretty tight your
biggest accomplishment wasn't even for
you it was for like your family that's
really dope though
well to be fair um he went on a hooker
bench first and then
to be fair uh buy the house like Main
Financial sense uh for the situation
we're in and uh I'm a minimalist so I
don't really like possessions I don't
want to have many possessions so cool
it's not all altruistic nice you don't
collect things no you have no you're not
you know Pokemons cars or nothing no so
what are you gonna do with all your
money if you keep making money don't
spend any of the money can I borrow some
money yeah minimalist hey give me some
money man [ __ ] it's the 11th minute
we're asking for money at some point
I'll probably transition now and you
know indulge more but yeah yeah what car
do you drive 2012 Lexus 2012. [ __ ] no
wonder you don't need a car what are you
talking about that's sick yeah yeah it's
Gonna Last you forever yeah it's Gonna
Last Forever it'll last you typical
Asian car did um you said that your your
dad lost his job because of the economic
collapse of 2008 yeah does that in any
way motivate your videos where you
expose like establishment issues and
governmental flaws
um no it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
really
frankly no definitely your Facebook
saying I was like oh wow yeah I was like
Wow Ryan I'll do something it's so
interesting it's like yeah no [ __ ]
way actually the [ __ ] away actually
so it's actually just a documentary he
got fired for sexual misconduct
it was just a coincidence he was taking
upskirts shots of the chicks at work
he had a GoPro on a stick
what those two things are not connected
huh wow what I was gonna say is uh
um
I mean my parents went through love the
Vietnam warship so I always had like
more of a Libertarian uh upbringing I
guess like more independent so I was
already kind of on that route and one
good thing was like going through that
you know
it makes you like more frugal and uh
more serious about like making money to
support your family so not not sense but
yeah so everyone kind of pitches in in
your family no
um
such as you how many how many brothers
and sisters do you have an older sister
you're older is she the [ __ ] loser
she's actually my assistant now exactly
that was family business that's cool
that's tight I keep the money in the
family yeah hey that's dope that is how
you do it yeah yeah you'll probably
fight like crazy but you'll trust her
you said you can drug her
that you can drug your assistance a
little hot tip about Hollywood
he's an OG yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
produce a lot oh geez that's true though
you can trust her and on top of that
yeah for sketchy stuff yeah yeah yeah
that's cool what's the hardest thing you
went through in your life would you say
hardest thing I went through
um probably just always feeling like an
outcast in school like uh I hated High
School Middle School elementary school
did you get bullied
yeah uh more so in elementary middle
school it all felt like Belgium
terrible
delivery for like miso soup it was not
miso soup why because you're getting the
wrong food in the wrong country you
gotta get the waffles Belgian waffles
they literally taste like waffles oh
Belgian fries yeah it tastes like
waffles they literally just taste like
fries really terrible food so you're
bullied in high school or you just felt
I uh not so much bullying in high school
I just felt like I just like didn't
belong at all like mindset wise like
everyone's immature or like the things
that they're into it's not where it was
High School in OC uh it was in Arizona
oh in Arizona okay yeah so um
no just didn't feel like I belonged
anywhere and
um I was like super awkward at the time
so really
like the only place I ever felt like I
belonged as a kid was in Taekwondo uh
that was like the first place where I
felt like I had like a community and you
know I gained like leadership skills and
stuff I did Taekwondo as well let's
fight
and this is the part of the video where
we fight 15 minute Mark two guys just
kicking the [ __ ] out of each other put
your best down below
[Laughter]
so yeah like taekwondo is where you
found a community yeah because uh so I
got into like three fights in Middle
School
um so my dad was afraid I was 33 oh
three okay I was like damn dude you're a
gangster no I lost like two wow so it's
uh one and two
amateur record but uh yeah my dad was
afraid I was gonna become the delinquent
which was a reasonable thing to worry
about sure yeah so he put me in
Taekwondo and I kind of like fell in
love with it right away
and uh kind of just like grew from there
I became an instructor
but then uh like started helping out and
stuff did you get into a fight after you
learned skills yeah and you do a back
spinning heel kick on their head it was
strange it like immediately changed my
demeanor so I just like stopped to stop
getting bullied after that what part of
your demeanor did it change uh just
gives you confidence because uh one
thing Marshalls does well is that it
gives you it gives like kids little wins
like multiple little wins every single
class they go to so it builds their
confidence uh really really well
so I guess it kind of just changed my
demeanor I came off more confident yeah
so I just stopped getting picked on
well we've reached the 16 minute 26
second mark this is probably really turn
up the heat real hot these were like
pretty easy so far yeah oh just wait
dude wow we thought this was really hard
already
um no um so we got to talk about
confidence right was there something
about yourself confidence wise that was
missing that you thought got filled in
later that you kind of like like
remember black and maybe seeing other
people you're like oh I didn't like that
about myself I can see you doing that
yeah um so I was picked on in school and
uh a lot for my sister growing up your
sister picked on you yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
you mean your assistant picked on you
you know what I'm saying yes
uh so it just made me like very not
vulnerable like I just wouldn't share my
feelings at all in like any way shape or
form she would just dunk on you or
something yeah sisters are the worst
dude he's got a bunch of them I got a
bunch of people I got a sister you hate
them too I don't hate them when you're a
kid they [ __ ] they dunk on you yeah
so uh I was like very not vulnerable at
all and it just made it really hard for
me to make friends or connect with
people or like connect with girls or
whatever so it wasn't until I read the
book models
um which is a kind of like a pickup book
but it doesn't teach you like stupid
stuff to say it teaches you basically
how to be more attractive by being more
authentic and more honest and more
vulnerable
so that book really changed the game for
me so after that I like slowly like kind
of like chiseled my way out of that you
mean vulnerable isn't like if you expose
yourself you felt that they were going
to use that against you yeah oh because
like if I share something yeah
sisters [ __ ] love that [ __ ] they'd be
like tell me your problems all right I
remember that yeah yes I would never
share my feelings or my insecurities or
whatever wow yeah you just helped me
heal some trauma right now dude awesome
thank you I should be a therapist how do
you tap into that Honesty for you
um
I don't know okay
how do I tap into that Honesty yeah like
what was the shift for you mentally like
like because you read the book right but
then you have to make you have to
implement the move yeah how do you how
do you do that how do I do it the book
really sells you on why you should be
authentic because uh like people connect
with other people's
insecurities and flaws
um
like you don't really connect with like
people that come off like perfectly but
you connect when people share like an
insecurity that you may have and you
like connect with them in that sense so
it really sells you on the importance of
it
and uh it teaches you that you should uh
take like tiny little baby steps here
and there to like gain some momentum
don't try to [ __ ] on a first date is
what they're saying yeah number one
pickup line oh if you're I mean it can
happen but like Don't Force It Don't
Turn it away but but this is a pickup
book huh
it's like a dating advice book yeah did
it help your dating oh absolutely yeah
so if you had to
find a way to make yourself more
attractive to your mom how would you or
your dad what kind of honesty what kind
of honesty would you put up I would
become a doctor or an engineer oh and
then your mama just get horny off that
yeah
great answer just to piggyback on what
Barbara's saying if you had to [ __ ] your
mom or your dad oh my God and you have
to do it or or yeah and you have to do
it the choice this is what the this is
the question we asked all fans on Jacob
what's been the best answer no it's it's
always it's you you always [ __ ] your dad
it's not usually the answer it's who you
pick and then the explanation why the
best answer so far was from Anthony Lee
he's a famous dancer he may maybe have
heard of him before do you know anything
he's a kid he's a noodle salesman he's a
shoe salesman a cobbler he also
he's mostly a cobbler he's also
suffering from copen right now on top of
this [ __ ] he he opened up to us about
how about how edible it would be for him
to have sex with his mother she's always
at the Hops and he started crying and we
all thought it was actually really
beautiful it was very sweet it started
off as a joke and then it got really
rude it was really nice yeah yeah and he
said that he would take her missionary
style but in a loving way and we all and
we all hugged him afterwards it was
really beautiful yeah so he could look
into her eyes yeah
because he loves his mother
piggybacking off of that well how would
you answer that question how would you
[ __ ] your mom your dad and you can't
answer you don't have to be a shoe
salesman or anything
or cobbler there's no prerequisites for
a good answer Mom or Dad yeah that's a
hard choice you gotta [ __ ] on them
pretty good too we all had to answer
this yeah and if you don't both you and
uh your parents are dancers yeah
oh yeah we didn't tell them that there's
like a gun to their heads and you don't
do it out of pleasure but you have to do
it I'll go with Mom okay
because Dad you would have to sedate the
butthole yeah you're not a bug guy
[Laughter]
you wouldn't [ __ ] your dad oh you're not
a black guy
my dad's got a great ass man let me tell
you
it's the cheeks so that's why you
wouldn't [ __ ] dad
yeah no other issues just that got it
man I know a blue man when I see one
he's not too much into 807. hey Bart
good follow-up good follow-up important
follow-up real good journalism there
so you're not a butt guy
foreign